Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's vegetarische Köfte!
Das ist eigentlich ein Widerspruch weil Köfte bedeutet so viel wie Fleischgericht
aber es gibt Fellah Köftesi und da wird einfach das Fleisch quasi "ersetzt" durch Weizengrütze.
Also ihr kennt's vielleicht auch unter dem Namen Bulgur.
Und Hamza hat mir grad was super spannendes erzählt, nämlich dass?
(H: Fellah heißt auf Arabisch Bauer!)
Ja!
Und dann habe ich gegoogelt und der Fellache, das ist das deutsche Wort dafür,
heißt auch in der damaligen Zeit eben übersetzt Bauer bzw Ackerarbeiter
und das fand ich eben super interessant!
aber jetzt komme ich nicht drum herum, euch hier erstmal zu zeigen, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Wir nehmen jetzt hier als Basis erstmal Weizengrütze fein. Das ist Bulgur İnce,
wenn ihr die türkische Marke nehmt, dann findet ihr das unter dem Begriff.
ist nämlich so ein bisschen verbreiteter bei den Türken sag ich mal.
Und das geb ich jetzt hier zuallererst mal in eine Schüssel, in eine große Schüssel.
Geb da abgekochtes Wasser dazu, das ist noch sehr heiß.
So, einmal mit dazugeben, ganz kurz verrühren
und dann einmal mit dem - mit irgendeinem Deckel oder hier wie ich es mache
mit nem Teller abdecken und 15min ziehen lassen.
So nach 10min konnte das Ganze hier schon mal ein wenig vor sich hin quellen
und jetzt geben wir Weichweizengrieß dazu und das quellt dann so in der Resthitze.
Und ich gebe auch schon alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu.
Da haben wir hier einmal Mehl nochmal für die Bindung, ein Ei
ebenfalls für die Bindung und jetzt habe ich halb und halb
Paprika- und Tomatenmark. Ich finde, dass Paprikamark echt nochmal so einen schönen
Geschmack mit reinbringt. Das gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit dazu und an Gewürzen brauchen wir nur
Salz und Kreuzkümmel, gemahlenen Kreuzkümmel.
Und anschließend reibe ich noch eine Zwiebel rein
und dann kneten wir das ordentlich, also es dauert schon so 10-15min.
Ihr könnt's auch wenn ihr die Bakery Boss Zuhause habt einfach mit der
Bakery Boss für 15min rühren lassen, das geht auch. Aber ich habe gedacht
für alle, die sie nicht haben, zeige ich das jetzt auch mal mit den Händen.
Ich mach das immer gerne so, dass ich mir dann den Teig
quasi aus der Schüssel auf ein Backblech gebe und dann richtig ordentlich knete.
Da habt ihr nämlich ausreichend viel Platz und noch ein Tipp von mir:
falls ihr merkt, dass die Masse ein bisschen zu trocken ist
einfach ein bisschen warmes Wasser noch nachgießen immer peu à peu,
also nicht so viel auf einmal. Und wenn ihr dann kleine Kügelchen
formen könnt ohne dass die bröckelig oder trocken aussehen,
dann habt ihr alles richtig gemacht. Also so sieht das aus.
Dann drücke ich das so ein bisschen flach, nehme den kleinen Finger und
drücke eine kleine Mulde rein und das machen wir jetzt mit dem ganzen Teig.
So!
(H: So, ich darf jetzt auch helfen, ne?)
Genau!
(H: Ich hab extra Handschuhe angezogen
weil ich hab ein paar Haare mehr als Kiki. Aber nur ein paar!)
(H: So! Schauen wir mal, wie das geht. Wie geht das jetzt?)
Mhh, zeig mal die Menge - ja, die Menge ist gut!
Einfach nur zu einer Kugel rollen
(H: Boah, das hört sich so ekelhaft an!)
(H: Mit den Handschuhen hört sich das nicht schön an!)
Hast du's?
(H:Ja!)
Ja perfekt! Ein bisschen flach drücken
und dann mit dem kleinen Finger eine Mulde reinmachen.
(H: Kann ich mit meiner Nase? Meine Nase ist kleiner!)
Toll!!!
(H: Voll cool, ne?)
(H: Hey ich bin Pro- ey, geh mal zur Seite!)
(H: Gib mal her.)
Okay!
Hamza, mach du das mal weiter, ne? Ich geh 'n Käffchen trinken!
(H: Jaja, geh mal!)
So, hab ich gemacht!
(K: *beeindruckt* Heeeey!)
(*langsamer Applaus von Kiki*)
(H: Ich hab keine Lust mehr. Kiki, mach weiter!)
Hast aber schnell den Geist aufgegeben ey!
(H: Jaja, reicht!)
Dat ging ja schnell!
(H: Reicht!)
(H: *männliche Stimme* Für einen Mann ist das - reicht das schon, ne?)
So, jetzt haben wir alles geformt, Hamza hat mir natürlich auch richtig gut geholfen, m-hm
(H: *schamlos* Natürlich!)
und jetzt gebe ich Rapsöl in eine Pfanne weil jetzt machen wir die Soße dazu. So!
Einfach ein bisschen Rapsöl rein und jetzt kommt Knoblauch zum Einsatz!
Ich mache das gerne so: ich gebe Knoblauch einmal in die Tomatensauce
und später - das zeige ich euch - auch zum Joghurt.
Und deswegen gebe ich's nicht in den Teig weil das wäre mir dann doch ein bisschen zu viel.
Daher hier nochmal den Knoblauch reingeben und auch richtig schön andünsten.
Zum Knoblauch geben wir dann noch Paprikamark und braten das noch so ein bisschen darin an
und löschen das ganze mit geriebenen Tomaten.
Das heißt ich reibe einfach Tomaten, die sehr reif sind,
ihr könnt aber auch zum Beispiel Tomaten aus der Dose nehmen.
Und dann löschen wir das noch ab mit etwas Wasser,
es sollte schon so eine flüssige Masse sein, und salzen und pfeffern natürlich.
Und wer mag kann jetzt zum Schluss noch ein bisschen Olivenöl für den Geschmack
dazu geben, das mache ich ganz gerne.
Und jetzt können wir die Soße auch schon beiseite stellen,
die brauchen wir gleich erst und wir machen jetzt hier einmal alles fertig.
Das heißt einmal Salzwasser aufkochen und die Fellah Köftesi,
also die Grießkügelchen, die Weizenkügelchen einfach reingeben und das dauert so ungefähr 10min
bis das Ganze dann gar ist und ihr merkt es auch daran, dass das Ganze dann an die Oberfläche steigt.
Bei mir haben sie jetzt ungefähr 18min gedauert, also ein bisschen länger als die angegebene Zeit
weil ich sie schon ziemlich groß gemacht hab.
Das letzte Mal hab ich sie vor anderthalb Jahren gemacht, da waren sie noch sehr klein
dann brauchen sie auch nur 10min. Aber ihr könnt zwischendurch auch
eine mal rausnehmen, anschneiden, schauen, ob alles schön gar ist.
Die dürfen auch nicht zu weich sein. Und jetzt einfach in die vorbereitete
Tomatensoße geben und da ziehen die auch noch mal ein bisschen Wasser ein.
So, einmal schön schwenken und dann sieht das auch viel appetitlicher aus!
Weil die schmecken wirklich extrem lecker aber ohne Soße -
schaut mal - wenn die jetzt besser mit der Soße benetzt sind, sieht's viel, viel appetitlicher aus.
Und das war's auch schon! Fertig ist das köstliche Gericht!
Unbedingt nachmachen und traditionell geben wir natürlich Petersilie,
ganz, ganz viel Petersilie oben drüber und ich freue mich schon, das nachher zu verspeisen.
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachkochen und tut mir einen Gefallen:
Abonniert jetzt, also spätestens jetzt meinen Kanal wenn ihr's nicht schon längst getan habt.
Dann verpasst ihr nämlich auch nichts mehr aus meiner Ramadan Reihe.
Ihr dürft mir gerne auch noch eure Wünsche äußern!
Wir haben nämlich noch nicht alle Videos gedreht, wir sind noch flexibel
daher schreibt mir gerne euren Wunsch rein, was darf nicht fehlen?
Jetzt aktuell natürlich eher orientalische Zutaten.
Ob süß oder herzhaft ist egal, wir sind sehr flexibel, ne?
(H: Ich vor allem, ja!)
Ja! Also, ganz viel Freude und euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag
und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen! Tschüss!